whenever bent gun sees an aeroplane he
thinks about the day that changed his
life nearly six years ago his daughter
was due home from Rio de Janeiro via
Paris he was waiting to meet her in the
arrivals hall at Munich Airport when the
news came through that the plane had
crashed over the Atlantic his daughter
was dead man palliat for that round
under your feet just falls away that's
let loose the last glimmer of hope is
that my child is gone as king I should
have gone before her but she is gone
mouse games all day may you have to live
with that it's nick mad ah that must man
seek meet up kill me but burnt Gantz
today has shaken of that sense of
hopelessness he set up a victim's
Association and commissioned expert to
investigate the technical issues of the
crash it is his way of dealing with his
daughter's death
now he is sent an open letter to the
families of the Germanwings victims
offering help and advice escaped
mentally the Saunders person-to-person
advice can be especially valuable Roman
to Willman mother to mother country
force in conversations like that I think
things can be said that otherwise would
remain unspoken suppressed if you liked
of an obeah neat jajaja common public
sympathy is also important he says a
good example was the wave of sympathy
for the 16 school pupils from the german
town of halton who died in the
Germanwings crash and gestures by public
figures can help such as the visit of
national leaders to the crash site in
the French Alps its hilt when see if
you're affected by an incident like this
it helps if you feel that your
government is supporting you in trying
to find out what went wrong they buy the
off cable and you feel supported if you
see that other governments are doing it
as well that the same determination is
there to explain and to help i hear
Vista villa de jesus go Shane of
tolkien's to heaven before he retired
band Guns was a manager in the aviation
industry he has never lost his
fascination with flying but the memory
of his daughter is always with him and
he doesn't want her to have died in vain
that's provided by musique media
technician it means you have to study
the technical problems intensively you
have to deal with similar accidents that
happen again and again the hope is of
course that you discover things that
will make flying safer option under mate
pflueger ck tomorrow bounce guns will go
on fighting to make sure that Airlines
and aircraft manufacturers learn from
crashes it's his therapy the way he
copes with the loss of his daughter